JAKE ARCHIBALD: Merry Christmas!
Yay!
It's the Christmas special, so
we've put on some Santa hats
and we've got some sleigh bells.
PAUL LEWIS: So I had an idea.
Thought what we could do is
we could talk about 2014.
what is your, what
is your highlight
what gets you yay
about 2014 web?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I
thought we opened
strong by removing the 300
millisecond click delay.
PAUL LEWIS: Did
that happen in 2014?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It
landed in stable in 2014,
so it definitely counts.
PAUL LEWIS: OK,
that's not a cheat,
that's just a
bending of the rules.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: No, it's 2014
when it landed in stable.
That's the rule.
So rather than double
tap to zoom, if we know
it's a responsive
site, then we just
remove the 300
millisecond delay.
It used to be that
you could only
do that if you disabled
pinch zooming, which
is-- we were punishing people
for making accessible sites
at that point.
PAUL LEWIS: For me, web
components big deal.
Obviously, first through
Polymer, but generally speaking
on the platform itself
you got Custom Elements,
you got HTML Imports,
got Shadow Dom,
you got really nice
ways for developers
to start encapsulating and
sending out their stuff.
So I like web components
I think they're
a good move for the web.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's been a
good year for fonts as well.
We've got the font loading API
which is-- it gives you events
when fonts load, which is handy
if you want to do something
different before the
fonts load in a document,
but also excellent if
you're doing canvas work.
PAUL LEWIS: OK, fair enough.
Moving on, web animations.
See, so we did--
In Chrome there's
a lot of re plumbing to
kind of put CSS transitions,
and key frame animations through
the web animations back end.
So all this stuff under
the hood got rewired,
and now all the
web animations APIs
are starting to land on top.
I think in the last week,
we got the ability to pause,
and rewind, rescrub the--
slow the timing down,
all that stuff.
So that's amazing.
And in dev tools,
it's not landed yet,
but there is going to
be an animations control
feature where you can scrub
animations back and forth,
see which animations
are playing per element.
You can see what the value
of all the animations are,
so that's amazing.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: In
terms of Evergreen,
there's is a point
to be made there.
We finally have it for--
PAUL LEWIS: WebView.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: The WebView.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes
in Lollipop, we're
got the auto updating web
view, which is very exciting.
All these new web features--
because developers,
like native app
developers, they seem
to use the WebView in places
where, well some people are
going to use it for entire apps,
some people are using it just
for smaller parts of their apps.
But they're getting the
latest and greatest.
And that's actually
a really nice thing.
It just brings that web
magic, the Evergreen mindset,
a little bit into
that native world.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And
when we did that,
I thought, about time
that that's updating.
PAUL LEWIS: I heard that
sentiment quite a lot as well,
but you made a
really good point.
We're the first people to do it.
There's no other
platform that is
shipping an auto
updating WebView.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh that
open source success story
of the earth-- the
picture element.
PAUL LEWIS: Ahh.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You have ice.
It is crowdfunding.
PAUL LEWIS: The man's a hero.
web, pretty pretty good.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Doing all right.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But.
PAUL LEWIS: 2015.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: 2015.
PAUL LEWIS: Get in.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I think the most
important thing for 2015 is--
PAUL LEWIS: ServiceWorker.
JAKE ARCHIBALD:
It's ServiceWorker
I'm glad you said that.
PAUL LEWIS: One hit wonder.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's the
start of a massive land
grab into what is being
previously considered
native-only features.
So I went onto the guiding
website a couple days ago.
It had this banner that said,
download our app because you
get offline and alerts.
I was looking at it going,
2015, the web gets that.
PAUL LEWIS: That's great.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So exciting to
lookout for 2014 on the web.
PAUL LEWIS: Yay.
Cracker?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: Now, I
discovered that many folks
around the world don't
observe this tradition.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's
a piece of cardboard
that makes a pop sound
when you pull it,
and inside there's a paper hat.
Let's pull a cracker.
PAUL LEWIS: Are you ready?
Are you ready for this?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So the
rule is that whoever gets,
whoever ends up with most of the
cracker is the winner, right?
Is that the?
PAUL LEWIS: Yes, that's
fair, and then you
get the present inside of it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Excellent.
Yay, winner is me.
I guess another part of the rule
is that British people thrive
on disappointment, and so the
thing you get inside a cracker
is part of that.
So yes, a plastic
frog, excellent.
That's something I will cherish
for the rest of my life.
What other delights are in here?
The hat.
PAUL LEWIS: It just screams
quality, doesn't it?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Well,
the other part of it
that you get the joke.
PAUL LEWIS: These are
special web crackers.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh.
PAUL LEWIS: So there may
be webby jokes inside.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK, here we go.
How do ghosts find
things on the web?
They use Ghoul-gle.
PAUL LEWIS: Wow.
Classic this.
Which HTML element did the
bride wear to her wedding day?
Address.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh,
the address element.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Why was
the accessibility tester
angry with the removal men?
Because they forgot
about the long desk.
On the image element--
PAUL LEWIS: It's a
long description.
Long desk, that hilarious.
All right.
Why did MVC framework blush?
Because it was Ember-arrassed.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Ember-arrassed.
PAUL LEWIS: It's
like embarrassed.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Brilliant.
Why did Mr. Gyllenhaal not buy
John Rezig a Christmas card?
Because he makes jQuery.
JQuery?
PAUL LEWIS: Jake weary.
Oh, fantastic.
It's a laugh a minute
around here, isn't it?
Yeah, Merry Christmas, ya f--